welcome back to New rockstars my Wookie
freaks it's me Tommy B once again it's
time for a bad boy breaking down a big
old bunch of bad batch specifically
episodes nine and ten the crossing and
the retrieval I loved this two-part
Adventure because it showcases each
member of the bad batch minus Echo and
their individual skills and
personalities also these episodes once
again shown a light on Omega being much
more capable of taking care of herself
I'm gonna treat these episodes as one
large breakdown because it is basically
one story but before we get started you
know I have to let you know where to get
this sick ass shirt it's all over at
nerd riot.shop we have Last of Us shirts
we'll be putting out a Mando season
three shirt soon lots of good stuff so
head on over to nerdrive.shop get you
one of these back to the bad batch The
Marauder is headed to a desert planet
and we get a sweet Star Wars western
music mashup I gotta say
foreign brought me back to my old days
as a cowboy most horses are afraid of me
they're not built for men like me I'll
be honest I'll also be honest I was
expecting some dueling at High Noon with
this episode but I think what we got was
better the batch minus Echo again who is
now rolling with Captain Rex are headed
to an old mine that Sid has acquired to
extract anything left of value in this
case we've got ipsium a highly volatile
raw mineral whose power is compared to
an explosion from a thermal detonator
now don't confuse this with coaxium from
solo a Star Wars movie which is highly
volatile in its powers compared to an
explosion from a thermal detonator Omega
is struggling with echo's exit from the
group as her already unstable life has
become even more unstable on the
opposite side Tech is unable to offer
any sort of comfort as to him Echo is on
another mission and that's all there is
to it this Dynamic is tested throughout
the episode with some pretty compelling
results Tech scanner reads an arabesh
and I picked up ipsum detected hey
baby's first translation not bad thank
you Eric Boss that sets a motion to
search for whatever amps you might be
left in this well picked over mine I
mean honestly it looks like one of those
old gold mines it just has dead canaries
in it well they do find some and it's up
to the slider framed Omega to reach it
and extract it using text extraction
drill Omega leaves wrecker alone to
guard The Marauder and it's immediately
stolen because Wreckers should not be
guarding anything and the bad batch is
now stranded at the mine Omega is able
to extract a few canisters with MCM
before the batch starts walking through
the Canyons to seek a Spaceport they
detected nearby fortunately they get
caught in a lion king scenario complete
with record falling
blue fossa style into the charging
animals but his records so he survives
and then they are caught in this wind
and dust storm that sends them running
into another mine and the ipsum is left
outside and detonated trapping them
inside in some sort of avalanche now
that they're trapped inside Omega feels
more lost than ever and requests some
time to be alone with her feelings she's
walking around she discovers a huge
deposit of ipsum in her efforts to
extract it she accidentally falls into
an underground river Tech sees this it
jumps in after and let me tell you why
this feels significant to me Tech is a
pragmatic man who thinks through the
odds of everything we saw that in the
first episode of the season when he's
dealing with the Escape pods and they're
likely to survival and then we saw it in
the speeder racing episode where he
becomes an expert racer by doing all the
formulas and all the calculations here
he just jumps in blindly without
thinking because Omega is in danger
you're only cares about saving her he
doesn't have time to do any calculations
he just jumps in that's growth baby
that's gross the two make it to the end
of the river and they see daylight after
radioing Hunter and wrecker they're able
to blast out with some of the ipsum now
this is a real do A6 ipsium to me
because iptum can either destroy things
or free you however you need it you're
able to make it to the nearby Spaceport
but Discover it is abandoned thankfully
there's a comms Tower and they're able
to reach Sid who tells them thanks so
much I cannot help you I think this is
the beginning of Sid turning on the bad
back she's breaking bad batch malagi
warned them in the speed erase episode
and it seems like Tech is at his moments
doubting Sid's loyalty but her being
completely unable to rescue them or then
tells them to wait a few days after they
kind of guilt trip her about having
covered for her many other times it
makes me think she's gonna you know
eventually turn them over to the Empire
the bad batch is now left in an
abandoned Town hungry and looking for a
way out we catch up with them again
hungry tired and cranky the bad back's
best hope of Escape might be in a broken
down skip now here skiff is kind of a
catch-all term for ships in Star Wars I
checked on Wikipedia and they had 23
different types of Skiffs just for land
my guess is if this is a technically a
skiff it's got to be a modified desert
Sports gift like this Luke Skywalker toy
drove or it's just a speeder they're
calling a skit you tell me in the
comments angrily please don't use any
kind of measure or care for my feelings
just yell at me and all cats powering
this gift reminds Omega that donkey
might still be on the Mariner and they
can they could track him and find the
ship by communicating with him gronke
actually is with Benny a young Thief who
works for the gluttonous greedy gangster
Mako who rules over the empty of mine
using kids as workers and paying them in
food and water occasionally Marco lets
Benny keep gonkey as a show of gratitude
the bad batch tracks down donkey signal
and confronts Benny then he tries to
escape on the repaired skiff and record
clotheslines him off it in what I think
is the funniest moment of this show so
far we find out that the Mind had
previously been controlled by the Techno
Union the Techno Union was a Commerce
Guild comprised of various technology
firms in the galaxy and put a prominent
role in the separatist crisis as former
Wat Tambor Allied it with Count Dooku
and the Confederacy of independent
systems despite holding a seat of the
separatist Council and pledging their
droid army to the Confederacy military
during the Clone Wars the Techno Union
maintain their neutrality in the
conflict with many of their subsidiaries
producing starships and weapons in the
galactic Republic nevertheless after the
conclusion of the war the remnants of
the Techno Union would be absorbed by
the Republic's successor the Galactic
Empire thank you Wikipedia now I know
what the Techno Guild was macro is
protected by guard Droids that stand on
two legs like Ned 8 and Kenobi and k2so
and perhaps they're left over from the
Techno Union's Reign if you know the
names of these Droids let me know in the
comments and again don't take my
feelings into account write it in all
caps and maybe say something about my
body as well if you see me walking
around with a little extra spring in my
step this week it's because our newest
designs just dropped over at nerdriot
dot shop and they're for the upcoming
Mandalorian season three we got two
shirt designs one with grogu's lovable
head and one with Den jaron's metallic
mug I think they're both cute and you
can make them kiss both designs have
arabesh wording that translates to the
foundling and the way respectively in a
style that's inspired by beskar Steel
I'm inspired by best car still every day
when you buy one of these shirts you get
the option to buy a special shout out on
our Wikileaks after show Once the series
starts in March I wish your girlfriend a
happy birthday or Eric Voss can say a
prayer for the foundlings that didn't
make it through the struggle whatever
you want also at nerdriot.shop our
quantumania line of shirts and hoodies
are on sale everything is 15 off until
the end of February get the new Mando
designs and all of our other merch
offerings at nerdriot.shop do it Benny
heads back to Marco's hangout with some
other kids are playing a dominoes-like
game it's not the bach these are smaller
chip like tiles Benny is devastated to
learn he is not the top earner but
rather an older kid Drake wins and he
gets a measly bowl of soup well Marco
pigs out and that's enough to radicalize
Benny in the bad Batch's cars and help
them figure out a way to lower the
shield so they can escape that's right
you don't give a kid soup he's gonna
side with the other side okay The Bash
repairs the ship Marco captures Omega we
have a standoff with Marco and his
miners his minor miners because they're
children and the bad bats but Benny
informs the workers that Marco is lying
to them keeping all the profits while
also eating all the good good food and
feeding them gruel for crying out loud
please sir man I have another the
workers turn on Mako and he falls
overboard into the depths of the mine so
Omega escapes herself and she leaps and
swings into the arms of Hunter this is
an example of Omega kind of carrying
your own weight now she's no longer a
damsel of distress Hunter is leaping to
save her but she recognizes that and she
escapes from the Droid by herself I like
this Independence I like Omega going in
this direction the bad batch is reunited
with sweet sweet donkey and they fly off
with the marauder for their next
adventure Mickey of Next Adventures I'm
off to mine that's all for me don't
forget to follow a new rock stars check
out nerdwire.shop and follow me at Tommy
bechtold that's all for now I have
spoken
[Music]